[Musique]
les messages que vous nous faites
parvenir le confirme
vous êtes nombreux à voir passer sur le
web d exemple de désinformation car bien
des cas ces contenus passent aisément à
travers des mailles des poids lourds de
l'ère numérique google facebook et
toutes les plateformes que ces géants
honte acquis au fil des ans
mais ces méga entreprises savent
qu'elles sont plus que jamais scrutée à
la loupe
quels sont au centre du combat contre la
désinformation si on s'attarde aux
plateformes web ou principales
plateformes web
à quoi ça ressemble à des informations
quand on regarde de plus près ça peut
prendre toutes sortes de formes
premièrement quand on pense aux réseaux
sociaux comme facebook twitter
ça peut être des textes des articles des
photos truquées des vidéos mais on voit
aussi beaucoup de désinformation sur des
réseaux sociaux qui sont strictement
basé sur des images interest instagram
juste avec problèmes ou des photos on
peut voir la désinformation on en voit
aussi sur des plateformes de messagerie
comme whatsapp ici c'est encore un
problème très répandu mais dans certains
pays où at sap est la première source de
désinformation parce que les gens
partagent des rumeurs l'envoient à leur
famille et à leurs amis au brésil au
brésil en inde donc un très gros
problème dans ces endroits là
et puis quand on parle des géants du web
on parle aussi des plateformes comme
amazon netflix et là aussi on voit
beaucoup de désinformation et dans tout
ça on se pose la question que font ces
fameuses entreprises facebook a mis sur
pied un partenariat avec des médias ou
lorsqu'un utilisateur signale un contenu
comme étant faux l'a démis devons lui
fier vont publier une mise en garde et
le cet article of facebook veut lui
donner moins de visibilité mais il
n'effacera pas c'est aussi quelque chose
que fait instagram qui appartient à
facebook google a aussi commencé à
mettre en évidence des articles faits
par des médias de vérification de fait
comme les décrypteurs donc ça commence à
être fait ce genre de partenariat là
mais souvent c'est une fois que la
fausse nouvelle a déjà été diffusé ben
voilà qui est tant mieux moi y est par
contre un domaine où ça m'inquiète un
peu plus où c'est un peu plus sensibles
c'est la santé quand on se dit santé on
dit souvent le mouvement antivaccin donc
une tour est fini l'an dernier par
interdire
les gens utilisent le mot clé vaccins
dans les images qu'ils partagent sauf
pour les images qui proviennent d'
agences de santé publique
facebook beaucoup de groupes et de pages
anti-vaccins ça existe encore ils ne
sont pas supprimés
par contre il leur donne moins de
visibilité dans les résultats de
recherche youtube encore énormément de
vidéo anti vaccins
et puis j'ai parlé aussi d'un amazon et
netflix ils ont été énormément critiqué
pour avoir diffusé pour avoir vendu des
documentaires carrément anti vaccins ou
avec la pseudo science alors ne même pas
abordé dans nos discussions la dimension
un peu plus politique des choses dans
quelle mesure les élections américaines
et tout ce qu'on a observé en matière de
désinformation c'est venu changer la
donne donc il ya eu un examen de
conscience et vu quelques changements
qui ont été faits surtout au niveau des
publicités maintenant facebook a mis sur
pied une base de données de publicité
pour qu'on sache qui derrière chaque
publicité pour faire une publicité
électorale maintenant il faut prouver
qu'on est bel et bien dans le pays où se
déroule l'élection en question ça passe
aussi beaucoup par des faucons par des
bots euros des robots donc beaucoup sur
facebook et twitter et s'est résolu en
efface constamment mais ça finit
toujours par revenir un autre jour des
nouveaux qui sont créés la
désinformation électorales ont aussi vu
que ça passe de plus en plus parler dit
fait que les vidéos truquées les autres
gueules oui voilà les hypers trucages et
leur facebook après avoir longtemps
refusé d'agir vient tout juste
d'annoncer qu'ils vont interdire
certaines vidéos truquées donc celle où
on fait dire à des gens des choses
qu'ils n'ont pas dit par contre il va
laisser les vidéos où on a enlevé des
mots ou changer l'ordre des mots et puis
on a vu aussi beaucoup en termes de
désinformation politique de la
propagande venant de régimes
totalitaires notamment enlevé avec la
chine que des comptes facebook
pro-régime avaient acheté et diffuser
des publicités pour laisser croire qu'il
n'y avait pas de répression de la
minorité ouïghoure
donc ça a été beaucoup critiquée
finalement tout était indiquent ils
n'acceptent plus de publicité de comptes
ou de médias financés par les
gouvernements donc on voit que sous
l'effet de la pression
les géants du web fusent parfois je
viens parfois par plier
et la pression au produit son effet mais
les observateurs sont unanimes les
grosses pointures du web n'en feront
toujours pas assez les fameux géant du
web appelons les comme ça que devrait se
faire en tout premier lieu il y avait
une priorité la dégager la première
chose c'est d'admettre leurs
responsabilités dans la protection de
l'intérêt public est d'admettre
également qu'elles ne peuvent plus se
cacher uniquement derrière le prétexte
qu'elles ne sont que des grosses
plateformes technologiques plus qu'ils
ont aucune responsabilité éditoriale
d'un média même s'ils ne produisent pas
eux mêmes ils sont devenus un medic en
tout notre modèle d'affaires est bâti
autour de ces contenus là quand on
touche comme facebook 2.4 milliards
d'individus sur la planète
quand on vend pour un milliard de
dollars de publicité politique
la moindre des choses c'est de s'assurer
que le contenu qu'on présente à ses
utilisateurs la et minimalement filtré
validé qui livrait une représentante de
facebook avait déclaré publiquement même
qu'ils n'ont pas de politiques qui
stipule que les contenus qui circulent
sur facebook doivent être vrai c'est
très loin quand même
oui on les voit pas assez mais c'est pas
à nous de les descendre et quel point on
peut imposer des changements à ces
méga-entreprises ont semblé qu'une
résistance de la part des pouvoirs
publics ya une résistance mais je pense
qu'ils ont un rôle à jouer au niveau de
l'éducation qualité récit médiatique et
des politiques également
or si on prend l'exemple ici au canada
vous savez très bien que le gouvernement
trudeau qui viennent se former a annoncé
dernièrement un cabinet d'union
et lorsqu'on analyse en fait les lettres
de mandat n'ayant absolument rien qui
mentionnait sur la teneur des contenus
d'information qui sont diffusés sur les
médias qu'ils soient nationaux ou qu'ils
soient sur ces plateformes numériques
services de pricewaterhouse prétend que
your un tiers des utilisateurs actifs de
l'internet qui sont des enfants d'âge
mineur il faut qu'on se commence à se
préoccuper aussi comment on va protéger
en fait
ces jeunes cerveaux la de la
manipulation qui peut arriver par la
désinformation les fausses nouvelles et
tout ça on doit donc s'en remettre à
l'autorégulation de ces grandes
entreprises de les laisser elle-même
fixer leurs propres règles sont
précisément ce qui se passe on leur
laisse décider pour elles-mêmes et là
faut comprendre quelque chose c'est que
évidemment elles ont aucun incitatif à
se défaire de ces fausses nouvelles de
cette désinformation
pourquoi parce que c'est l'économie qui
est derrière vous le savez très bien
ces informations souvent fausses très
sensationnaliste sont aussi des pièges à
cliquer et c'est extrêmement payant pour
ces plateformes
elles n'ont aucun intérêt en fait à
encadrer ou à réduire le nombre de
fausses publicités mais en face de ces
entreprises il ya nous il ya les
utilisateurs qui ont une responsabilité
aussi et ça nous amène précisément là
nous faisons partie du problème et de la
solution et de la solution quand nous
faisons ce travail sur ces plateformes
de partage et sans même avoir lu validé
la date valider ou vérifier la source
d'où provient l'information donc je
pense qu'il ya vraiment un effort
collectif à mettre en place est pour le
moment parce que les gouvernements
s'impliquent peu dans cet enjeu là pour
le moment parce qu'on est aux prises
avec l'auto régulation des plateformes
la vigilance de l'eau de l'utilisateur
de mort probablement la meilleure
protection dans le contexte actuel
[Musique]